thank you
is the world getting better or is it on
the verge of collapse
stuff on sagmeister emphatically
believes that things are looking up and
in the art exhibition Now is better
showcases a bold new way to convince the
world that he's right he takes actual
paintings from the 18th and 19th
centuries disassembles them and creates
new works by juxtaposing them with data
visualizations of just how much things
have improved since the good old days
some Works chart the incredible decline
over the centuries and deaths on the
battlefield from famine and from extreme
weather events While others show how
much cheaper food and lighting have
become in real terms one piece documents
the explosion in the number of guitars
per person on the planet an indicator of
growth and Leisure and entertainment
while another charts the persistent
belief that crime is always Rising
despite its well-documented decline a
heralded graphic designer who has
designed album covers for Jay-Z the
Rolling Stones and Lou Reed he's won two
Grammy Awards including one for his
design of the Talking Heads box set once
in a lifetime
born in Austria in 1962 he's called New
York City home since the 1990s and he
draws on sources such as our world and
data human progress and the work of
Stephen Pinker who has written the
forward to an art book of the Now is
better series that's due out later this
year in a wide ranging conversation
sogmeister tells me why it's so
important to acknowledge and defend
material progress why art and commerce
are not enemies and what he loves about
the new world he's adopted as his
homeland and how that ties into the Now
is better project
[Music]
Stefan sagmeister thanks for talking a
reason wonderful thank you so much so
give me the elevator pitch on the Now is
better show well it's basically comes
out of my interesting long-term thinking
because I discovered uh that there are
really two ways to look at the world one
is from a very short-term perspective
what is happening right now which is
basically what all media looks at it and
if you do that almost by definition
everything looks bad because things that
are going bad go bad quickly
scandals catastrophes and so on while
many things that develop well that's
developed positively do so very slowly
and don't really work in a short news
cycle but
and that's really what the show is about
to look at the world from a long-term
perspective
20 years 50 years 200 years I think we
have a couple of pieces that are 500
years and where if you take that point
of view many many things look very
positive was there a moment where you
were like aha this is this is what my
work is going to be for the next few
years dear boss well I was lucky enough
to get one of those residencies at the
American Academy in Rome and one evening
I was sitting next to a lawyer who was
the husband of one of the residence
artists and he told me that what we see
in
Poland in Hungary in Brazil at the time
really means the end of modern democracy
he was a highly educated person and I
looked it up I went back to the studio
that night and quickly Googled it what's
the story of this modern democracy when
did it start and if you went back 200
years there really was only one the
United States I went back 100 years
after World War One
um there were I think 18. and now we
have just a good 80 I think 87
democracies that the un's there's their
democracies so it turned out that this
smart man had really no idea of the
world that he lives in but I discussed
it with other people and was immediately
surprised how much pushback I would get
because you know specifically
there were certain people in this case
it was mostly on the political left who
somehow want to believe that things are
going down right that there is some sort
of an investment in that what do you
think that is I think if you're an
activist it might be easier to get
people over to your cause if you can
tell them how bad things are and I think
there's a truth to that many of us being
so overwhelmed by all the negative news
that we get on a daily basis give up and
say oh this is so terrible we can't do
anything anyway one of the paintings
that you have is titled richer and
poorer and it shows in 2029 of the
global population was living in poverty
compared to in 1990 35 of the global
population was living in poverty but
then you ask how many people believe
poverty has gotten worse and 55 percent
of people believe that poverty has
gotten worse over the past 30 years only
12 12 percent believe that it's gotten
better which it has so are people
misinformed or do they want to believe
that they're living in a bad period I
think it's a mix I think it's uh it's a
mix of I don't believe that the media is
inherently evil or or it's trying to
mislead people no they believe what
they're saying they believe what they're
saying and they know
specifically now in the last 20 years
since we have clickable links they know
what people like
the media gives us what we like and we
all prefer negative news over positive
news I am just like everybody else I
also do prefer negativity and I actually
think to create pieces that are positive
is somewhat more challenging because
they by themselves tend to be less
interesting the vast majority of pieces
when they have anything to do with
commentary of Life social commentary
anything will be critical or negative
one of the series of pieces in the
collection look at how much richer We
Are One actually looks at Global GDP and
how much richer the planet is not
fascinating one painting is Bright
Lights time worked for an hour of light
and in 1800 that was six hours of work
for an hour of light in 2000 was two
seconds work for an hour of light you
have another one about the hours working
a job and it's amazing that not only has
the amount of work you have to do for a
second of light has come down but the
amount that we work is much less how do
people respond when you say well
actually you're working a lot less than
your your father probably or your
grandparents
on the work front I think
there is an interesting phenomena going
on right now in France you know where
you have all these protests going on uh
against
moving the pension years up yeah and I
think that's a direct result of this
information not being part of our daily
discussion because if everybody would be
aware that we now live double the amount
of time than we did 100 years ago then
it's just logical that we would have to
work a little bit more before we can go
into our retirement you have a piece
called artists lawyers and doctors and
this is the number of artist lawyers and
doctors in the U.S artists 2.5 million
lawyers 1.3 million doctors 900 000. is
it a sign of a good society that there
are more artists than doctors it's
definitely the sign of a good society
that it would be able to sustain a very
large group of people that has very
little function we can't do anything
before we'd have shelter before we can't
breathe and eat and so all of these
other things and specifically the
artistic impedance
is only be able to even to be pursued
once we have shelter and once we have
the caved paintings are of the animals
that Hunters caught so exactly you you
can paint after you've eaten yeah but
probably not before and they're done in
a cave once you are sheltered right
right yeah and you have another piece
the number of playable guitars in the
world which has increased massively so
that speaks to the idea that it's a
pretty good world where a lot of people
are expressing themselves creatively
that's an indicator that we're doing
pretty well yes the numbers with the
guitars is absolutely
astonishing because it went from a
couple of hundreds
decades ago to tens of thousands right
now so it meaning the the increase is
just incredible going in the other
direction you have a painting that talks
about the decline in the number of
deaths from natural disasters which is
also something that again if you're I
would say if you're over 40 you should
have no problem realizing like when you
were younger you would hear all of these
stories about you know hundreds of
thousands of people starving to death or
dying because of earthquakes or volcanic
eruptions or tidal waves and you don't
really hear that very much anymore but
we think the world is getting worse on
that school yes well it's exactly what
we talked about in the beginning is that
there has never been a news report about
there was no earthquake in California
today right so all the positive things
just go unreported but even the absolute
number of people dying yeah is a
fraction of what it used yeah and that's
certainly true of things like pandemics
and whatnot so however bad covet was the
response was quicker and more effective
than the 1918 flu epidemic yes I almost
found it fascinating that doing kovitz
one of the broads that was used the most
in the media also in the New York Times
was unprecedented right even though the
people who wrote that clearly had the
knowledge that this is not unprecedented
maybe unprecedented this year but for
sure not I'm president of this Century
right where you had AIDS that killed 30
million people you had the Spanish Flu
with
between 50 and 100 million people and so
on you know a number of the pieces talk
about immigrants and immigration being a
positive thing you yourself are an
immigrant from Austria to New York
um you first came here in the late 80s
you settled here fully in the early 90s
what Drew you to New York and how does
that reflect uh in your work well I came
here first right after high school it
was a high school gift from my
brother-in-law or it was in 81 so New
York was from its now perspective you
know pretty bad shape I would say crime
was incredibly High uh but it was just
fascinating to me even though I was born
in a very pretty small town in Austria I
was always attracted by big places I
think it's also a lovely mix of American
friendliness which might be odd because
you know New York is not known as a
friend exactly but ultimately it is
quite open and I haven't done a piece
with it yet but I've just come across
and I checked it and it seems to hold up
I just came across data that showed that
refugees not immigrants refugees that
have been in this country for 25 years
or longer
have a 30 percent higher income than the
average American and with immigrants
okay I believe it but the refugees is
pretty astonishing that refugees in
their lifetime not in the beginning when
they come here but in their lifetime
would surpass
the locals I find that to be the
strongest indicator that there is an
American dream that that is alive that
I've come across and I know it has been
incredibly fashionable to say that the
American dream is dead and even I feel
sort of like silly sitting here uh
claiming otherwise but those numbers
point in that direction your background
is as a graphic designer which is more
functional than me you know than art
right
do you see a sharp distinction that many
artists are many critics would draw
between kind of commercial art or
instrumental art and real art is that a
false dichotomy
I can argue it both ways if people ask
me what do you call yourself I
definitely am a designer and the work
that I'm doing here I would also see is
design work
simply because I would say that there is
a functionality to it and which I find
pleasing but I also totally understand
that many artists would not want any
functionality to their pieces that's the
whole point of art right is that it
resists being used for some other
purpose and I would say even there would
have to really say it's the whole point
of Contemporary Arts because art by
itself if you look at his historically
of course also has many functions right
many of the most famous artists in the
past did very functional work you know
Michelangelo designed candles
stakeholders Leonardo obviously did many
many other things there is no such thing
as pure functionality it's all on a
scale talk a little bit about your
process for the the pieces in this
exhibition basically you buy cheap
paintings from the 18th and 19th century
and then you put data visualizations
over there it originally started with
pieces that we still had in the Attic in
the house that I grew up with that came
from my great great grandfather store
who was an antique dealer in Western
Austria and the stuff that didn't sell
bound up still beings towards there to
this very day so the first pieces really
came from there yeah and since then I'm
by now I think connected to about 30
auction houses all of them in Central
Europe mostly Austria's but so what do
you pay for what do you pay for a piece
that you're going to paint over I think
they're all for sure under 4 000 Euros
which you know I'm kind of a beneficiary
of the fact that specifically 19th
century out but also 18th century art is
very much out of fashion right now what
is the pleasure of painting over you
know a piece from the early 19th century
with a data visualization that shows how
much better things have gotten but we're
not really painting over we're really
basically taking the piece apart we are
plucking holes into it and we are
inserting the new data so the piece if
you want this destroyed which I had
given some thoughts about meaning
ultimately I solved it for myself
thinking that if somebody in 200 years
takes my work
that they found at tiny auction houses
and makes a new piece out of it I think
I would be very happy about it but the
process really is I buy these pieces at
auction by then I've already had
received the photo so I ultimately try
out designs and these can be inspired by
the data they can be inspired by a color
scheme they can be inspired by Form they
can be inspired by a composition they
can be a reaction on the existing piece
but ultimately by and large I'm trying
to go against the composition that is
existing because that sort of seems to
create
the kind of tension
that ultimately
makes a good new composition how much
did you increase on average just make it
up if you have to yeah you know if the
average painting that you've started
with yeah cost four thousand Euros what
was the average that you were selling it
for how much did you increase the value
I think it's probably times two or three
but of course there's also significant
cost involved in creating this you know
like there is an incredible amount of
just hours that go into that not just
myself or from my own but uh there's a
whole team working on this in the
Brooklyn Navy Yard there is costs in the
renting the space and all of that stuff
so there is that but ultimately I
actually tried to keep the price as low
as it's possible that it still makes
sense I want this to be in as many homes
as possible that's the functionality of
it because ultimately the goal and in
there for really it's embedded in the
concept right that these things hang on
somebody's wall as a reminder that what
they just read on Twitter doesn't mean
it's the end of the world you've worked
with a number of very you know globally
known uh recording artists like Lou Reed
like the Talking Heads like the Rolling
Stones and you did an album cover for
the Rolling Stones which album was that
again richest about that one yeah so you
know that's like a platinum record what
what does it feel like to know that your
images are going out to you know a
million people or more fantastic you
know it's also something that I love
about design is that it's a pretty
Democratic way of working where you know
we do the Jay-Z cover where the first
print one was five million for the price
of twenty twenty five dollars yeah uh
which I don't think there is a
publication in the out world that
reaches those kind of numbers I very
much love the fact that design tends to
live within our life yeah I see myself
as a communication designer more so than
a graphic designer I think the challenge
specifically for somebody like me is to
make these things
interesting enough
that even though they are positive
people will be engaged and you know
that's the challenge